-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
whose memoir, "Foolish:
Tales of Assimilation,
Determination, and Humiliation"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
Sarah Cooper, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show
in person this time!
-I'm in the seat.
-Last time you were here,
we talked about
your very popular videos
where you lip-sync Donald Trump.
-Who?
-Yeah. I'm wondering, because of
how many of those you did,
which one of us you think is
more sick of hearing his voice?
Me or you?
-Um, probably you.
-See, I think it's you
because I --
At least when I do his voice, I
get to make him say what I want.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Where you were, like,
locked in to, like,
actual things he said.
-Right. It's more terrifying.
-Yeah.
-Right. Yeah. It's, uh --
[ Laughs ]
The things you're saying
are actually kind of funny.
The things he's saying is --
You are scared.
-Yeah.
-You're just scared. Yeah.
-This is --
This is a wonderful book.
-[ Gasps ] Thank you.
-You're very welcome.
And a memoir. We actually --
We were talking --
We were at a dinner,
and we were talking
about writing a memoir.
And you actually
have some advice
to anyone who would take this
leap into writing a memoir?
-Yes. So, the one thing
I wish I had done
before writing this book
is read a book.
-Yeah. That's a really smart,
like, step one.
-It's just -- I wish
I had just picked one up.
But, see, the thing is, I skim.
-Yeah, you're a skimmer.
-I'm a skimmer.
I don't really read.
Who reads? Does anybody read?
You just buy books.
You don't actually read them.
So that was my first mistake.
And I do want to apologize
to the gentleman
who reviewed the book
on Goodreads
who said, "Sarah admitted that
she wrote most of this high,
and it shows."
Um...
[ Laughter ]
-That seems like
a positive review.
He's calling you
a truthful person.
-I am, but should I have
written in the book
that I wrote this book high?
Should I have done that?
I don't know.
But I think if you skim it
while high it's really good.
It's a really good book.
-That's a very interesting way
of saying it.
"Look. I was high. Don't beat
yourself up. Just skim it."
-You know, write high,
edit sober, submit drunk.
-There you go. You talk about
your comedy being very --
[ Applause ]
Yes. This is --
This is good memoir advice.
You talk about how your comedy
is very popular with dads.
Could you extrapolate on that?
-Dads love me.
They love me. They love me.
Too bad they're married.
-Yeah. Not all of them.
-Not all of them.
Not all of them.
But, yeah,
the first time I got recognized,
I was walking
my little dog, Stella.
She's a cute little Cockapoo.
And she was taking a giant poop.
And I had my mask on,
and so I bent down
to pick up the poop,
but I couldn't get
the little green bag open,
so I took down my mask to lick
my fingers to open the bag.
Very sanitary.
And this little girl,
10-year-old girl,
came over and she said,
"Are you Sarah Cooper?"
And I was like, "It's happening.
It's happening."
And I was like,
"Yes, I'm Sarah Cooper.
Are you on TikTok?"
[ Laughs ]
And she was like, "No.
My dad sends me your videos."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Heartbreaking.
-My dog saw the whole thing.
I mean...
-Yeah.
-It was really embarrassing.
And at first,
I was like, you know,
maybe he was just kind of,
you know,
a younger
sort of millennial dad.
You know, not that bad.
-Sure. Yeah.
-But then I was doing
my Netflix special,
and Marisa Tomei came over to me
and she said,
"Sarah, can I get
a picture with you?!"
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
Marisa Tomei wants
a picture with me?!"
And she was like,
"No, it's for my dad."
-Oh, yeah...
That's how you know.
Once you get
that second example...
-But hello to Marisa Tomei
and her dad.
-And her dad.
-Yes.
-You talk about
how you are dating again.
-Yeah.
-You write about your divorce
very openly and honestly.
-Yes.
-And you're dating again
and that men are....
You find men to be robots
currently in your
dating experiences,
and you have some red flags.
-I do.
-Okay. What are some red flags
we should look out for?
-Tall with a good head of hair.
-Bad? That's bad?
-See, Elon Musk
is building these robots
because he needs, you know --
he needs little androids
to build his Teslas.
-Yeah.
-And so he knows
that a woman will overlook
just about anything
if a man is tall
with a good head of hair.
-So that is likely a robot.
-That is likely a robot.
-Okay. Interesting.
-Short bald men are okay.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-They're okay.
-Yeah.
-Um, let's see. Monotone voice.
-Okay? So if he uses
the same tone of voice
to say, "I went to Duke,"
as he does to say,
"I'm gonna [bleep]," that's...
-Yeah.
-That's a robot.
Watch out for that.
-The funny thing
is he doesn't seem excited
about either of those things.
-Either of those things.
It's a red flag.
-Yeah.
-The other one is if he responds
to really cute text messages
in a weird way.
Like, if you wake up
thinking about him
and you send him a text message
and you're like,
"I woke up thinking about you,"
and he responds, "LOL."
Um...
-Classic robot tell.
-Classic robot.
-So helpful.
This is also very helpful.
You're doing a very kind thing
with your wedding ring.
You're divorced.
You're gonna auction it off.
-I am.
-For a good cause.
-Yes.
-What is the cause?
-I'm such a good person!
Um...
I, um -- I'm giving it to the
Entertainment Community Fund...
-That's very nice.
-...to auction it off.
-This is helpful
during strike times.
-Yes, during strike times.
Because I -- I wanted
to be part of the WGA
for so long, the Writers Guild.
And in 2020,
I was actually able to join
and get my health insurance
through the WGA.
And without
that health insurance,
I wouldn't have been able
to get divorced.
-That's fantastic!
-So I'm donating
my wedding ring.
-And you can go
to your Instagram page.
-Yes. Go to my Instagram.
-Sarah Cooper, everybody.
"Foolish" is available
wherever you buy books,
but please support local
and independent book stores.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."